alors une des particularités de ces
rixes comme de tous les autres
personnages
ils ont aînés énorme semble savait mais
on dit quelquefois que les dessinateurs
se dessine un peu dans leur personnel
moi je dis que ce faut absolument fou
plus juif radio aftra christophe sellin
faudrait m'obsède jean lèques l'article
d'eric schmidt timoré stoner honda est
juste les gagnants d'un art de paris
zanfan babaorum a cru en nous
bonjour monsieur uderzo
c'est ainsi que les architectes de
visionnaire imaginer l'avenir à l'époque
d'astérix pour albert uderzo
ce rêve est devenu réalité grâce au
petit guerrier gaulois avec cette maison
de campagne non loin de l'antique lutèce
sais pas mais des disques parce que bon
je suis assez discret et puis je voulais
être perdu un peu au milieu de la nature
et vous et là je suis servie en ce qui
concerne la nature de plus de plus
j'adore le chaume c'est un rêve
d'enfance la maison au toit de chaume
c'est je pense que tous les enfants
vivent un peu de ça
c'est ce qui colle d'ailleurs un peu
avec le côté gaulois pas bien sûr
d'ailleurs la guerre ne sais pas si vous
fumez il ya une avec joie les rondes et
à son pavillon de forme sur la tête et
un domaine gaulois avec tout le confort
moderne
mais albert uderzo a aussi des relations
privilégiées avec un fournisseur gaulois
de menhirs en ce moment c'est le
meilleur
les habitants de ce village mais est il
encore besoin de les présenter
y at il quelqu'un dans cette salle qui
ne les connaît pas ah bon ça va mettre
des scellés mais abc l'image je vais
faire les présentations
cette grande lutte et la demeure du chef
incontesté du village le redoutable
abraracourcix c'est moi qui vont être
sur ce bouclier
je suis le chef après tout je dois
écrire les courses tant les gorilles et
après en attendant on est un peu d'ordre
dans la maison sans oublier refuserait
d'y vivre
voici idée fixe la mascotte du village
et fidèle compagnon d'obélix le célèbre
fournisseur de menhirs pourra m'aider
dans mon travail tue ca bellick ce n'est
pas que je vais t'en as doute
l'intelligence d'idée fixe mais je me
demande quelquefois s'il n'est pas un
peu petit pour tenir celui qui vient de
parler avec tant de sagesse n'est autre
qu astérix le meilleur guerrier du
village le célèbre astérix dont les
aventures avant dans les meilleures
librairies ont été traduites dans toutes
les langues
pour vous dire vrai dire voit d'ailleurs
ce n'est pas du tout la vie quotidienne
des gauloises mais aux lois avait une
vie quotidienne certainement beaucoup
plus mouvementée beaucoup plus dures et
difficiles
là nous avons nous avons créé en quelque
sorte des gaulois qui qui ressemble
beaucoup aux français ou aux allemands
ou aux espagnols aux italiens
aujourd'hui on sait par exemple que les
gaulois face aux patriotes wê et coupa
net à des prisonniers il est planté sur
des pics à l'entrée de rapides hommes
parce que c'était une forme de devin a
créé 2
il mettait les trophées ne s'était pas
des têtes de sangliers s'étaient et tête
de romain ou des tabous d'ennemis
rien de nouveau non nous avons fait
bonne chance moi j'étais départ idée
fixe
c'est plus facile j'oubliais nous avons
croisé une patrouille de soldats romains
ils sont fous ces romains
alors je me traîne
vous est-il arrivé oui nous avons croisé
deux goals ou faut dire qu'ils avaient
tâches et des sangliers bâlois continue
à nous ridiculiser
c'est cette potion magique qui les rend
invincible pénates vraiment 410 euros
mes ancêtres moins jusqu'à l'âge de 7
ans c'était des romains puisque j'étais
italien mes parents sont arrivés en
france et n'ont pas eu la nation
italienne française pardon tout de suite
ils l'ont eue en 1934 quand j'avais mais
c'est en 1924 sud les français et j'ai
appris à l'école primaire faire mes
ancêtres s'était pas de payer tous les
romains mais c'est lé wall web alors bon
va pour les gaulois
je vais pas du tout été gêné de cette
chose parce qu'après tout aux lois ou
romain tout ça c'est un peu la même
chose
bien que nous refera sa différence et
c'est ainsi que commence notre histoire
dans le célèbre village gaulois
sous un ciel bleu azur ses habitants
coule des jours paisibles
savoure le chaud soleil du printemps et
l'avenir est plein de promesses
c'est peut-être dans une ambiance
similaire que le petit alberto aleandro
a vu le jour le 25 avril 1927 à 7 heures
du matin dans le petit village gaulois
de films
- les gaulois je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que j'ai appris que 7,6 donné
mes ancêtres à la baisse est en effet
une leçon de deux choses qui que ma
maîtresse d'école nous faisait faire je
vais souvent raconté elle nous a dit
fabriquer une douloureuse avec de la
terre glaise et les fabriquent une
gauloise avec un taille en champagne bon
et donc j'ai commencé mes premières
hugues bauloise on était ronde puis
après j'ai appris qu'elle n'était pas
ronde à cahiers d'école du petit albert
parmi ses premières oeuvres
cette illustration des fables de la
fontaine des douze ans il fait preuve
d'un talent de dessinateur
exceptionnelle avec stupido ses premiers
coups de crayon dans le domaine de la
bande dessinée
dès cette époque les gros nez de ses
héros deviennent son image de marque
avec claude pinard il gagne à l'âge de
18 ans un concours de bande dessinée
organisé par le quotidien france soir
devenu dessinateur professionnel il fait
ses premières armes au magazine ok avant
de s'essayer aux reportages illustrés
c'est à cette époque aussi qu'il tombe
sous le charme de ses yeux merveilleux
vous êtes très gentil mais moi je ne me
reconnais pas du tout et vous suppose on
tue pour nous c'est non mais c'est pas
ça et moi c'est soit 5 g de produits non
c'est pas ça tout le monde des îles
magnifiques bon basket une eau non non
non vous voyez bien comparer non mais
c'était c'était c'était une
c'est une des cinq verrez c'est
effectivement nous étions jeunes mariés
en 1952 53 oreille et ça recommence un
contrat de mariage
wen jun d'accord al banna tantôt j'ai
pas mal à mon ami un cadeau pour toi oh
comme c'est gentil
à
mes fleurs préférées oui j'ai surtout
pas osé le dire alors à ses parents je
vois ce qui se passe avec les miens je
voulais mon temps et si bon si c'est pas
un métier à dounia voir l'épaule sur un
buteur mais eu des moments un peu
difficiles
trois ans après le mariage leur fille
sylvie vient au monde pendant dix ans je
suis pas parce qu'en fait il était
extrêmement concentré et c'est un vrai
travail mais c'est vrai que après nos
noms et on est on n'existait pas quand
tu travailles il ne voit pas on peut se
mettre un entonnoir sur la tête on a
fait derrière les séries que maman y
voit rien du tout mais un an sinon oui
bien sûr il était on était très complice
est un travail qui n'a pas l'air sérieux
mais qui finalement c'est un travail pas
sérieux qui doit être fait sérieusement
et beaucoup de concentration et enfin je
dis ça les gens comprennent pas
d'ailleurs parce que souvent on me le
dit plus maintenant mais au barreau me
disais bon vous faites ça mais vous
devrez métier c'est quoi en 1951 albert
uderzo rencontre un homme avec lequel il
va écrire plus tard une page d'histoire
de la bande dessinée entre rené goscinny
et albert uderzo
l'entente est immédiate c'est le début
d'une longue amitié goscinny écrit des
scénarios et des bulles de texte et
pertinents uderzo se charge de créer des
dessins humoristiques
le premier personnage issu de cette
collaboration et l'indien oumpah pah
ou papa oui ou papa est une est une
petite aventure que nous avons vécu une
saignée moins qu'une aventure que nous
avons vécu depuis pas mal d'années que
nous avions vécu pas mal d'années avant
de pouvoir réussir le lever quelque part
où personne n'en voulait personne n'en
voulait et à tel point d'ailleurs c'est
que ce personnes neuf ont négocié n'est
parti pour des raisons x y z trop long
pas expliqué ici a dû repartir aux etats
unis
il était envoyé spécial là bas et il a
comme nous n'avions pas le plat n'avions
pas à placer ou pas par an en france
aignan belgique puisque nous travaillons
à ce moment là pour la belgique
également il a il a pris les planches
fait son bras il et j'ai essayé de les
vendre aux états unis
penser que quand les américains ont vu
arriver ce petit français qui essayait
de de le faire de l'humour avec les
indiens américains
la paire graphique ils nous ont pris
pour des petits rigolos et il aura venu
piteusement avec ses plans ce qu'ils
n'ont donc qui sont restés au sommet
comme ça pendant au prénom part l'un des
bus sous sadate
je parle le premier mon papa date de
1951 et en fait il est sentir mieux sur
58 donc sept ans après en plus des
aventures doug papa uderzo réalise des
bandes dessinées d'un genre plus
réaliste avec les personnages de tanguy
et laverdure créé avec l'auteur jean
michel charlier uderzo révèle toute
l'ampleur de son talent de dessinateur
dès cette époque les auteurs
apparaissent en marge de leurs aventures
sur cette image d'un numéro de juniors
albert uderzo serre la main à son
associé rené goscinny un geste qui
augure peut-être de leur succès commun
un petit guerrier gaulois avec un gros
nez de longues moustaches et un casque
ailé astérix n'a peur de rien sauf
peut-être de voir le ciel lui tomber sur
la tête
le signe y voyait en afrique sans
personne à ce petit malingre qui était
plutôt un contrant papin contre emploi
mais surtout un un antihéros
contrairement à ce qui se passait par
habitude dans la bande dessinée de l'or
et il m'a demandé de faire un petit
bonhomme
et puis comme je fille têtue celui
relais s'accompagner d'un personnage
plus plus fort et qui n'était pas du
tout prévu au programme habilis devait
pas tu ne veux pas paraître dans
l'histoire de 6 et puis finalement il
s'est rendu compte qu'il était très
utile d'avoir un personnage qui était en
sorte un faire-valoir l'oral et hardi
finalement on revient toujours aux
couples aux comics le clown blanc et le
clown auguste on en sent pas ça
le compagnon de ces rixes et obélix
ronsin et la particularité d'un bel x
c'est qu'il a un gros dés alors il a
abandonné mais il n'ya pas que le nez
qui est gros pardon avait rixe non il
est un peu enveloppé
c'est ce qui dit il les lui n'est pas
n'a pas les cheveux blonds ou jaune
j'ai cru au départ qu'il avait les
cheveux verts parce qu'il faut dire que
je suis daltonien chauffons le rouge
vert et après on m'a dit qu'il avait des
feux rouges alors donc ils iront c'est
un bon garçon qui m'a l'air d'être assez
sympathique et je dois dire que
personnellement j'ai un petit faible
pour lui qu'il me ressemble je ne sais
pas mais j'étais faible pour lui il a
une particularité il adore la gente
féminine
c'est exactement - st
le premier numéro de pilote fondée par
uderzo et goscinny avec les épisodes des
aventures de tanguy et d'astérix paraît
le 29 octobre 1959 les aventures
d'astérix réalisé dans une ambiance
survoltée paraissent d'abord sous forme
de feuilleton
il faudra attendre 1961 pour voir la
publication du premier album édité à
10000 exemplaires
la réaction des lecteurs dépasse les
rêves les plus fous d'uderzo et de
goscinny
dès 1967 il dépasse le chiffre mythique
d'un million d'albums vendus à cette
même époque
le petit gaulois arrive enfin dans les
librairies en allemagne à l'époque nous
avons édité cinquante mille exemplaires
et les débuts étaient assez difficiles
l'album ne se vendait pas les libraires
nous disait que le format était trop
grand pour leurs présentoirs que les
albums étaient plus grands que le
journal de mickey que ça n'avait pas de
sens de vouloir lancer un album français
parce que cela ne marcherait pas des
histoires français ça n'avait pas de
sens
les chiffres des ventes prouvent le
contraire goscinny et uderzo ont
découvert la recette du succès les 31
albums publiés à ce jour ont été
traduits en 60 langues
plus de 280 millions d'exemplaires de
leur histoire ont été vendus à travers
le monde
dès 1968 astérix investi les salles de
cinéma
c'étaient d'autres éditeurs dans
l'époque qui sans nous prévenir avait
conclure l'accord avec suite au dessin
animé bugs qui s'appelle à quissac la
belle vision et qui avait cet éditeur
dont il y avait commandé un film mais un
film un dessin animé qu'il devait qui se
traduisait le premier album d'astérix le
gaulois et qui devait être coupé en
feuilleton pour la télévision donc été
d'une qualité très inférieure
on sait que la télévision en général ne
peut pas avoir de grands budgets pour
faire des longs métrages comme font par
exemple les américains et donc nous
avons assisté à une séance avec rené
goscinny
très curieusement on apprend voyant
apparaître ce film dont on n'est pas du
tout n'était pas du tout au courant et
on a dit bah écoute et oui c'est un peu
dommage que nous n'ayons pas été
prévenus parce qu'il y avait un deuxième
film aussi était en cours et là on a dit
on veut bien pour le 1er mai le deuxième
vous arrêter et vous brûlez la pellicule
est donc bon puisque c'était fait on n'a
pas voulu
gêné trop l'éditeur qui avait quand même
mis beaucoup d'argent maintenant et se
trouve que des propriétaires de salles
parisiens ont visionné le film et on dit
c'était les frères sion skis de parra
france eq si on dîne nous on veut pour
nos salles de cinéma quand on est auteur
on est toujours un peu trahi
on se sent un peu trahi parce que
curieusement les gags qui peuvent
fonctionner sur une bande dessinée sont
pas forcément des gars qui peuvent
marcher pour un film d'animation
on peut expliquer la chose c'est que à
la lecture la lecture demander s'ils ne
se fait à la vitesse du lecteur tiers
qui peut revenir en arrière si l'apport
compris un film lui et suit son chemin
et si le lecteur ne sut pas ne comprend
pas un gag en deuxième ou troisième
degré c'est fini il augmentera plus
c'est toute la différence
enfin son étude en tout cas et voilà
donc il faut que ce soit là aussi
il faut ça sous est une une adaptation
d'une bande dessinée faut que le texte
s'adapte à la forme cinématographique
est tout un art qui est un art un peu
différent de la bande dessinée et qui
fait que sa demande être offre traduit
différemment
pour autant le succès du film confirme
la popularité des invincibles gaulois
christian clavier alias astérix et
gérard depardieu dans le rôle d'obélix
font un tabac au box-office en france
des coulisses ou dimensions monumentales
plusieurs mois de tournage
deux mille cinq cents costumes des
milliers de figurants
les producteurs n'ont pas lésiné sur les
moyens pour faire de mission cléopâtre
un spectacle digne des superproductions
hollywoodiennes
la fils d'un producteur qui connaissait
bien fils d'un producteur connu en
france la fille de claude berri
puisqu'il faut donner son nom lui
connaissait parfaitement astérix et un
jour il dit à son père papa tu devrais
quand même prendre une à une une option
sur ces risques pour faire un film long
métrage avec des comédiens parce qu'un
jour quelqu'un te prendra vie décès de
neuf et le père que ne sais pas du tout
à ces rixes avec ça existe encore alors
il s'est informé
ils étaient très impressionnés par les
chiffres de ventes aussi bien en france
qu'en allemagne dans certains autres
pays
il a fait le plus gros budget tous les
films français qui ont hissé jusqu'à
présent il a il n'a pas menti
aussi bien le premier que le deuxième je
souhaitais évidemment qui est des
comédiens qui me paraissaient à faire ce
les rôles c'est surtout le le rôle
d'obélix que je voulais voir avec
depardieu
un choix qui se confirme sur le grand
écran
les histoires d'astérix et d'obélix sont
tellement universel qu'on peut les
traduire facilement dans toutes les
langues
en plus elles ne se limitent pas
vraiment à l'an 50 avant jésus christ
elle parle aussi de l'époque actuelle
ces histoires sont très critiques à
l'égard de notre société et de nos
concitoyens avec leurs petites jalousies
et leurs manies il est tout frais ça
sent le poisson dans pas ce poisson pas
frais le combat de david contre goliath
nous le connaissons bien ici c'est le
combat du village contre la grande ville
je suis originaire d'un petit village de
pêcheurs près de hambourg
pendant près de huit cents ans nous
avons mené exactement le même combat
contre la grande ville de hambourg que
le petit astérix contre les romains
avec carré
obélix est un peu notre tennis local et
astérix ressemble à chelles ces deux
personnages comiques symbolise un peu la
ville de cologne mais on pourrait dire
aussi qu'il reflète les deux facettes de
notre caractère
l'un des deux a la stature de gleeks un
peu lent à la détente
il à l'astuce du paysan chez lui c'est
le plus vif le plus futé d2 c'est donc
le personnage d'astérix les deux
correspondent bien aux caractères des
habitants de cologne
a b x et y ajouter ce menhir
bah oui pour guérir notre druide tu ne
vas pas encore vous dire que j'ai mal
fait aux astérix a beaucoup de points
communs avec nos autres souabe à cause
de nos ancêtres communs les celtes sans
doute nous sommes des têtes de mule tout
à fait digne des irréductibles gaulois
c'est un petit gars de cologne astérix
est un des nôtres pour être honnête je
n'imagine pas astérix en souabe ou en
petits gars de cologne pour moi il
serait plutôt d'allemagne du nord
le coup de crayon inimitable d'uderzo et
l'humour incisif de goscinny crête un
univers dans lequel les lecteurs
découvrent à chaque lecture de nouveaux
détails surprenants les père d'astérix
connaissent bien les petites manies
zélés défaut de leurs concitoyens et la
vie en gaule en 50 avant jésus christ
n'est pas si différente de notre propre
quotidien
uderzo fait preuve ici aussi d'un
remarquable sens de l'observation
il s'agisse de l'acropole ou d'un
amphithéâtre romain
ses dessins sont basées sur des études
minutieuses
sans oublier un faible pour les
allusions de la noce villageoise de
pieter bruegel au film satiricon de
fellini il puise dans un répertoire
éclectique
après l'écriture du scénario
le dessinateur se met à l'oeuvre en
réalisant des esquisses et des dessins
au crayon
le format original est deux fois plus
grand que l'album finale pendant cette
phase de création uderzo peaufine le
moindre détail
contrairement à de nombreux collègues il
réalise lui même tous les dessins depuis
les personnages jusqu'au paysage un
travail exigeant qui demande des mois de
concentration
la prochaine étape nous mène dans les
studios de la société edc les
collaborateurs de l'entreprise travaille
dans le secret absolu
aucun détail ne doit filtrer à
l'extérieur
c'est dans ces ateliers que sont
réalisées les deux prochaines étapes de
la fabrication d'un album
l'une d'elles est le coloriage avec des
aquarelles un travail délicat que le
daltonien albert uderzo confie à sa
coloriste attitré elle me confie le
crayonné le crayonné des planches
originales sont à la taille la qualité
de travail sur ce crayonné je viens y
mettre lancre tel ancrage du thym créons
une fois le trait de crayon noir si alan
qu on le gramme
ce qui est malheureux il ne faut pas
moins de huit mois au collaborateur des
studios
le tc pour recopier les dessins à
l'encré de chine et pour le coloriage
des planches un travail de haute
précision pour toute l'équipe
à l'issue de cette étape les dessins à
l'encré les planches colorier sont
superposées une page de l'album est
prête
parmi les personnages célèbres
immortalisé ainsi figure sean connery
lino ventura charles laughton kirk
douglas
les beatles
un hommage à zorro
don quichotte en napoléon
le président jacques chirac
et bien sûr les auteurs eux-mêmes les
mystères de l'histoire n'ont pas de
secret pour uderzo et goscinny
pourquoi le sphinx n'at-il pas donné
facile nos gaulois préférés ont visité
bethléem servi de modèle pour la statue
de la liberté et expliquent l'origine
des étoiles sur le drapeau américain
leur voyage les mène dans le monde
entier et de temps en temps leur périple
dans le passé frôle l'époque moderne
dans les aventures d'astérix
même les bulles de texte sont un art à
part entière le répertoire va du
dialogue canin en passant par
l'interprète du cirque maximus et les
jurons gothique jusqu'au langage
administratif
oui quelques astérix aux logs avertis
ont pourtant découvert des erreurs
le violon par exemple n'a été inventée
qu'au xviie siècle quant aux caleçons
ils ne sont pas parus qu'un siècle plus
tard la brouette était elle aussi un
ustensile inconnu des gaulois mais il
des réseaux ne demande pas mieux que
d'apprendre il n'hésite pas ainsi à
modifier lance du chaudron de panoramix
après la découverte d'une erreur par ses
fans j'ai rencontré des historiens
d'abord qui sont en général des gens
ferment très gentil soir avec huit ou
neuf is grand historien qui sont des
gens très gai très très amusant bien que
venant de la sorbonne est un professeur
dans des grandes un des grands lycées
je m'attendais à voir des gens très
sérieux et je me faisais tout petit
parce que je me disais comment ils vont
accueillir
eh bien ils accueillent très bien ils y
sont ils sont absolument aimable sauf
que le dernier en date que je ne connais
pas mais qui a écrit un livre qui vient
de sortir d'ailleurs et qu'on vient de
m'offrir et qui s'appelle par toutatis
et évidemment toutatis c'est un mot
qu'on sait qu'on utilise nous dans le x
parce que le vrai nom du you always
c'était tout à tess nous n'avons s'est
amusé à le changer un peu et dans ce
livre il explique que tout ce qu'on
raconte sur la gaule et les gaulois
c'est complètement faux astérix
melix l'amusant cette extraordinaire il
adore mais tout ce qui est beau il est
complètement faux
panoramix on sait c'est le druide de le
druide c'est l'homme savant du village
c'est l'homme intelligent qui sait tout
qui connaît tout mais qui ne veut rien
dire parce que les druides garde alors
leur secret est entre autres le secret
de la potion magique
d'ailleurs dans aucun manuel d'histoire
vous avez la recette de la potion
magique parce qu' il n'a jamais voulu
l'inscrire et donc personne ne la
connaîtra moi même je ne la connais pas
si chaque année ça vous pensez bien que
je m'amuserais pas à faire des petits
dessins can see you je vendrai de la
passion ma vie je serai aux anneaux
ravix notre truites
je suis inquiet obélix est malade il est
tout récent de garantie n'a rien mangé
avant le manger 2 janvier
autant dire qu'il a mangé alors le voir
le maître riz et pour cause ces
histoires de gaulois font un triomphe
dans le monde entier en 1981 albert
uderzo se consacre à un projet qui lui
tient particulièrement à coeur
la création du parc astérix huit ans
plus tard son rêve devient réalité
à 35 km au nord de paris les visiteurs
rencontrent les célèbres héros du
village gaulois
c'est la plus grosse récompense qu'on
puisse avoir quand je vois les enfants
autour de personnages bel xrx leur joie
lancent ugtt et il l'a vraiment l
impression d'avoir servi à quelque chose
sont elles savent pas prétentieux de le
dire mais c'est vrai rôle en france
c'est quelque chose
le précieux de l'extraordinaire
quand on doit avoir beaucoup de respect
parce que
c'est un âge merveilleux albert uderzo
se sent chez lui dans ce village gaulois
les enfants reconnaissent astérix et
obélix
mais pas leurs créateurs et c'est tant
mieux car le dessinateur préfère rester
dans le rôle de l'observateur anonyme
pour mieux savourer le plaisir évident
des enfants
il ajouté
oui guipavas rooney qui l'incliné
souvent ceux qui disent qu'il a fondée
et uderzo ne serait pas eu des réseaux
s'il ne cherchait pas à tourner en
ridicule ses propres produits de
marketing
une campagne publicitaire dans la rome
antique mise en place par la société
obélix sarl enhco le passé et l'époque
contemporaine se confondent
tout comme astérix et obélix uderzo et
goscinny sont des amis inséparables ils
étaient complémentaires
c'était le temps des mid et al cela dit
chacun avait sa famille ils n'étaient
pas collés ensemble tout le temps à se
raconter des blagues ou à imaginer des
nouvelles bêtises mais quand ils étaient
ensemble c'était une collaboration
intense il se complétaient parfaitement
quand l'un des deux était à cours
d'idées pour des coups tordus l'autre
prenaient le relais
j'ai toujours eu l'impression qu'il
s'entendait à merveille
quand je pense aux gags qu'ils ont fait
remonter tous les deux goscinny était le
plus actif des deux monsieur bêtise en
personne albert uderzo et est plus
subtile un blagueur plus discret
goscinny lui ne faisait pas dans le
détail
quand il avait une idée il était
incapable de la garder pour lui
rent avantage les titres à deux c'est
que on se parlait d'une chose qu'on
connaissait bien et l'a envoyé une idée
de votre envoyé l'autre une idée en
amenant une autre comme ça une seule
fois j'ai eu la mauvaise idée de faire
une blague
il m'a appelé et m'a dit alors aisé
c'est un long silence je fais ben alors
j'ai entendu aussi un long silence de
l'autre côté parce qu'il va être
complètement défait et julie espèce
d'idiot ses formidables comme d'habitude
et je me suis fait enguirlander il
arrive libre alors sans brutale en
espèce d'imbécile ne recommence plus ce
genre de choses parce qu'il était très
anxieux comme le sont tous les auteurs
et il n'avait pas la grosse tête il
savait qu à chaque fois c'est un athènes
un éternel recommencement
on se remet en cause et donc voilà et
qui lui quand il recevait les premières
planches et ben ils étaient les premiers
à les relire est bon ils étaient ils
semblaient être heureux et il m'a jamais
fait la moindre remarque sur ce que
faisaient
en quelques images parfaitement ciblé
les histoires d'uderzo et de goscinny
révèle les faiblesses de l'être humain
comme ici la dispute et la
réconciliation de deux amis
la mort inattendue de rené goscinny le 5
novembre 1977 est un choc terrible pour
uderzo et tous les passionnés d'astérix
quand c'est arrivé évidemment je n'ai
pas sauté à pieds joints
l'inventeur de sexe pour moi c'est vrai
que c'était était mort c'est la première
des règles sont prévues
ça y est on avec une belle aventure la
fin de de rené c'est la fin de ces rixes
et bon seulement ait eu un tas de
facteurs qui est bon qu'ils m'ont
troublé qui monte qui monte le bus vers
et ravir bon à la presse
évidemment s'est emparé de l'événement
est difficile après s'est emparée de cet
événement à l époque on le savait on est
toujours y est à côté un vote et
nécrophage les crocs face dans la presse
qui a fait que le signe était mort est
inséré c'était mort maintenant n'est pas
mon avis il disait tenir à signer et
finit à ces rixes j'ai trouvé tout de
même que le rôle que je vais jouer dans
cette aventure est ici c'est quand même
et vu par fierté par orgueil une
réaction
le grand fossé est le premier album
publié sans rené goscinny
avec ce dessin uderzo créé un petit
monument en souvenir de l'ancienne
équipe il est toujours au dessus de ma
tête quand j'écris un
non pas que je crois au spiritisme a nié
toutes ces choses à laquelle on fait
beaucoup allusion en ce moment dans sa
vision n'est pas là mais quand ces cris
et crée une idée je me pose la question
je me dis est ce que lui aurait était
satisfait et il est est ce que ce gag
est ce qu'ils auraient été satisfaits de
ce gag je me reporte toujours sur dieu
sait si je le connaissais comme il ne me
connaissait d'ailleurs nous avons
travaillé 26 années ensemble et donc 18
avec astérix
donc il y avait une telle osmose si vous
voulez que fatalement on savait comment
l'autre allait réagir
lui savait comment vous allez
interpréter son texte et moi je savais
exactement ce qu'il devait
ce qui devait y avoir en dessin sur son
texte publié en 1980 le premier album en
solo d'albert uderzo raconte l'histoire
d'un village gaulois coupée en deux par
un fossé une tranchée qui divise les
habitants des deux moitiés du village
nous avons visité un jour le mur de
berlin avec uderzo et il nous a dit plus
tard que c'était là qu'il avait eu
l'idée du grand fossé à l'époque ce
grand fossé traversait le monde entier
s'était à l'époque du rideau de fer qui
ne se limitait pas seulement un berlin
au fond les habitants de berlin ouest et
restes appartenaient à un même peuple
il voulait vivre ensemble il faisait
partie d'une même famille cette
situation m'a beaucoup impressionné et
c'est pour cela qu'il a écrit cet album
un peu comme les deux vins gaulois de
ses propres albums uderzo montre
l'avenir dans le village gaulois il n'y
a plus de fossé à berlin il n'y a plus
de murs mais cet album est particulier à
plus d'un titre
au début j'ai fait la connaissance d'un
camarade d'études à l'université dans le
nord de l'allemagne qui avait un peu de
mal à se faire comprendre dans la région
de la souabe nous avons donc organisé
pour lui un cours de patois souabe en
guise de manuels pédagogiques
j'ai fabriqué un album d'astérix en
patois en collant des étiquettes sur les
bulles et l'album a eu un succès
inattendu dans mon entourage tout le
monde voulait un exemplaire mais j'ai
refusé parce que c'était un travail de
fond du coup mes amis m'ont un peu forcé
la main pour que j'envoie mon exemplaire
à un éditeur la version souabe d'astérix
remporte un succès immédiat
aujourd'hui près de trente éditions en
dialecte sont en vente dans les
librairies allemand j'ai essayé de
respecter les particularités du patois
au lieu du traditionnel par jupiter
je disais bien sûr iluv stuttgart au
lieu de nettoie les latrines
je disais tu feras une semaine de
corvette balayeur dans le dernier album
j'ai remplacé une injure invoquant un
dieu indien par la formule que le
diabète emporte vous dire qu'en france
moi je voudrais pouvoir le faire j'en ai
parlé un jour une ministre de la culture
je lui ai suggéré ce que ça serait de
votre avis une bonne idée elle m'a dit
avec moi méfiez vous parce que le
nationalisme régionaliste en france peut
être quelquefois assez violent on en
sait quelque chose et ça serait
peut-être quelque chose qui serait pris
en main par les par les régionalistes
pour en tirer un profit politique
on
peut-être du badminton mais sinon
c'était falbala et tout le monde l'a
reconnu en tant que femme je suis très
très flatté
tout va bien mais pas dire qu'il me voit
avec les yeux de l'amour fallait bien
trouver un modèle vous avez sous les
sous le sous la main donc c'était plus
facile pour moi ok x mon ami tu es
amoureux qui voit la fin de balade c'est
extra dire ceux en revenant à ses
personnages qui a énormément marqué
alors que c'est un personnage qui est
apparue vraiment l'une façon très
succinct puisque quand on se souvient de
l'album on l'avait très peu elle n'est
plus jamais revenu et et tout le monde
part le falbala donc il faut croire son
personnel qu'il faudrait peut-être que
je réutilise un jeu d'une façon plus
sérieuse mais quand même parce que les
femmes
enfin bischoff minimes ya mimine bien
sûr tout comme pour ses narrations de la
vie quotidienne des guerriers gaulois
uderzo trouve le ton juste pour décrire
les femmes gauloise pacifique
épanoui en harmonie avec leur
environnement
la solidarité des villageoises et sans
faille avait été bannie mais jamais vous
deux
c'est pas fini non puis je savoir
pourquoi tu a invité ses de rigolo parce
que ce sont les deux meilleurs gags et
du village à jamais
l'émancipation dans la gaule antique
bonne mine doit de la potion magique et
se transforme en super gauloise est le
premier à faire les frais de sa nouvelle
force et le bagarreur à pénitents et
marchands de poissons ordralfabétix
tout petit un long temps parce qu'après
j'ai réagi comme tout le monde tout
petit j'étais pas très consciente et
c'est surtout je dirais les enfants de
la famille qui m'ont fait prendre
conscience de ça c'est pas vraiment mon
père savait ce que les hommes l is lucky
luke
oui j'aimais beaucoup il a vécu qui met
beaucoup le journal de spirou et
j'aimais de sam lecture quand même me
astérix est vrai pour moi c'était un
univers qui était loin d'être étranger
mais que je laissais pour travail de mon
père est ce un cousin de la famille qui
n'a ferrand elles connaissent ça quand
même parce que ses premières leçons de
l'école nous a dit un jour que la
maîtresse sera demandée il leur a parlé
des druides et le dira mais les druides
masquer des frênes et panoramix parquet
c'est à ce moment là était pas très
connu je crois que la maîtresse se poser
des questions des quelques petites
déviations
les générations de lecteurs se sont posé
une question pour même le druide
panoramix ignore la réponse
qu'arrive-t-il à obélix qui est tombé
dans la potion magique et en petit comme
tout le monde sait si laval une bonne
gorgée du breuvage magique
obélix redevient un petit garçon
un rêve du dessinateur ou le portrait de
son petit fils
c'est réciproque entre le petit-fils et
le grand père c'est une osmose
incroyable j'ai rarement vu ça mais je
pense que ça doit être vrai chez tous
les petits enfants avec leur grand père
oui on dit je suis vaguement gaga ou non
message bayonnais la bisontine à quatre
pattes dans le couloir c'est assez
intéressant
obama depuis maintenant parce qu'il a 7
ans donc ils comprendraient pas que son
grand père soit à quatre pattes mais
j'ai été longtemps et gagne pas c'est
vrai
là je vais vous montrer un autre à
dernière une diction qui est un album un
peu particulier qui est un album de
crayonnés pourquoi l'album ne craignez
parce qu'en général quand le dessinateur
fait une bande dessinée il la commence
par faire du crayon bien sûr et aussi
sucrés aux îles leur passé à l'encré
noire et le crayon disparaît et c'est
quelqu'un c'est pas moi qui ai eu cette
idée
un collaborateur qui a eu l'idée de
scanner les crayons avant de les passer
au noir qui fait qu' on a trouvé que
c'était intéressant pour les lecteurs et
voilà ce que ça donne ça donne ceci qui
fait que maintenant la intel progrès
dans la photogravure qu'on n'arrive plus
à savoir si c'est du crayon ou cissé
d'imprimerie on a presque envie de
prendre une gomme pour effacer
moi j'ai toujours été très prudents avec
le succès parce que je touche je suis un
garçon qui craint toujours de
s'installer dans confortablement dans un
succès et on ne sait jamais un succès si
comme un temps il va durer et j'ai trop
vu deux ans qui était très en vue du
succès qu'ils avaient le plus avoir de
succès et d'être terriblement malheureux
de ce renversement de situation
et j'estime que dans le métier que nous
faisons est un métier qui est à la fois
pour plaire au public et pour plaire au
public il faut lui servir les choses
qu'il aime
si demain je fais un album qui me plaît
pour public il n'a aucune raison de
continuer à me lire il peut très bien le
lâcher comme ça donc il faut il faut
avoir toujours la notion de ce succès
qui peut s'arrêter du jour au lendemain
retour à la vie la gauloise non loin de
lutèce
c'est ici que le maître vient se reposer
et chercher l'inspiration pour ses
nouvelles idées
mais que serait la maison d'un génie de
la bande dessinée sans une pièce
consacrée aux oeuvres de ses collègues
bien que vous êtes là et je vais en
profiter pour vous montrer mon mur d'or
jeudi vaut mieux encore il est coutume
d'avoir un livre d'or et moi je préfère
avoir un mur c'est beaucoup plus
pratique c'est plus grands et là vous
voyez différentes signatures de calvi à
fait remis à fred
bref mais la plus importante de ces
signatures celle ci celle de rené
goscinny qui en 1973 m'a dessiné son
personnage fictif était un détective
américains à new york et qui avait une
particularité qui nous amusait tous nous
dessinateur c'est que ce personnage
cours est toujours derrière ces voleurs
parce que pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'il ne savait pas dessiner
d'automobiles dit la mort de sa de tout
ce qui était mécanique ce qui fait que
bombe à son personnage courait voilà bon
vous avez évidemment tout de suite
derrière assez récemment pas besoin de
vous le présenter
et puis quelque chose d'aussi à laquelle
je tiens beaucoup c'est la signature
vieil ami jean michel charlier qui était
aussi un merveilleux scénariste et avec
lequel fait fait évidemment les dessins
de tanguy et laverdure
bien connu d'ailleurs des
téléspectateurs puisque ça donnait lieu
à un feuilleton qui s'appelait le fameux
logiciel
lors la voilà assurances ou x le barde
qui lui a une particularité il un grand
des pointus bon ceci dit il a pas que ça
non plus il a une une situation très
particulière parce que alors qu'ils les
bardes
donc il doit chanter l 1 0
ils sont fous et comme les gens une fois
personne ne veut l'écouter
assurance tous risques bonjour vanille
et moi j'aime bien mon barbe
j'aime bien parce qu'il est malheureux
on lui fait en lui fait on lui fait des
tas de trucs très très méchant comme le
fait de l'attacher à un arbre quand tous
les autres se goinfrent de
dorothy sans oublier bien sûr et je
trouve qu'il a bon caractère de rester
dans ce village
mais il restera encore longtemps
aussi sûr que le banquet traditionnel
dans le village des irréductibles
gaulois et c'est là aussi que notre
histoire se termine nos guerriers
savourent leur sangliers et la cervoise
en bonne compagnie et que les passionnés
d'astérix se rassurent leur héros ne
tarderont pas à découvrir de nouvelles
aventures
à moins que le ciel ne leur tombe sur la
tête